seid ihr eigentlich für die frauenquote
wenn ja dann habt ihr was mit diesen
beiden gemeinsam markus söder und
friedrich merz okay der jetzt eher
zähneknirschend wenn aber zwei
konservative männer für die frauenquote
sind dann hat doch eine 40 jahre alte
idee politisch endlich gezündet oder
dann kann doch eigentlich auch die
kanzlerin aufatmen die mal sehr
drastisch war als es um den aktuellen
frauenanteil im deutschen parlament ging
und das ist genau der frauenanteil den
auch der sudan in seinem parlament hat
ich heiße andrea mora und ich bin
politische korrespondentin im zdf
hauptstadtstudio hab also jeden tag mit
politik zu tun und ich kann euch aus
meiner beobachtung des betriebs hier
sagen politik ist immer noch männersache
und die frauenquote ist und bleibt
politische machtfrage ihr wollt die top
vier gründe wissen warum das so ist zum
beispiel auch warum die frauenquote
immer noch so ein looser image hat dann
bleibt man dran
das war jedenfalls schon ein echter
überraschungscoup dass sich die coco auf
ein gesetz geeinigt hat das den
frauenanteil in firmen vorständen erhöht
wer jetzt plötzlich alles dafür ist
markus söder csu fordert frauenquote in
dax vorständen oder friedrich merz der
konservativste unter den kandidaten für
den titel vorsitzt er hat lange die
frauenquote nur für die zweitbeste idee
gehalten was besseres ist ihm dann aber
auch nicht eingefallen er ist nämlich
jetzt irgendwie dafür habt ihr diesen
legendären auftritt mit alice schwarzer
bär markus lanz gesehen
das ist nur ein geste aus japan will
muss fühlen
machen wir es kurz wenn du hast nichts
besseres einfällt werde ich dafür stimmt
erst wohnte ja es tut sich was
und trotzdem steht es um den
frauenanteil in der politik faktisch
nicht
ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut wo die
idee für die quote eigentlich herkommt
hier grundgesetz 1949 unsere verfassung
da steht unter artikel 3 absatz 2
männer und frauen sind gleichberechtigt
der staat fördert die tatsächliche
durchsetzung der gleichberechtigung von
frauen und männern und wirkt auf die
beseitigung bestehender nachteile hin
gleichberechtigung ist also keine idee
von irgendwelchen radikal feministen
sondern steht seit 70 jahren in unserer
verfassung auch die debatte um die
frauenquote ist schon ziemlich alt als
die grünen 1979 die innerparteiliche 50
50 quote eingeführt haben war friedrich
merz mitte 20 und markus söder war ein
teenager dass die beiden jetzt erwachsen
sind nicht mitglied bei den grünen aber
für die quote heißt nicht dass ich sonst
viel getan hat in der politik eigentlich
geht es da gerade er rückwärts drei
kandidaten hat die cdu gerade für den
cdu-vorsitz und damit auch den kanzler
job ja kandidaten
die hat ja mein kollege florian neuhann
hier bei insight politics gerade
vorgestellt märz röttgen laschet keine
frau und für die spd tritt an ein mann
die fdp hat sich gerade neu aufgestellt
nicht mehr generalsekretär in sondern
generalsekretär an der seite des
vorsitzenden nur bei den grünen ist noch
offen wird es der mann nicht zu
vergessen die afd
die hat sowieso ein ganz eigenes konzept
radikaler antifeminismus und den trägt
sie ins parlament wann immer sie kann
ich bin oft im bundestag und das
krasseste beispiel für die
frauenfeindlichkeit der afg dass ich mal
im plenum gesehen habe war als britta
haßelmann gerade dabei war den geringen
frauenanteil in der afg fraktion
aufzuzählen
da rief jemand aus der fraktion der afd
natürliche auslese würde darauf
der regierungs gang dass es einen
zwischenruf gab aus der afd
wovon natürliche auslese gesprochen wird
zitat wir werden es im ältestenrat
ansprechen würde sie bitten ich würde
sich witten an grundregeln des umgangs
des politischen demokratischen zu halten
überhaupt beobachte ich bei den
bundestags debatte über die frauenquote
ganz oft grundsätzlich ist da zeigen
sogar junge unions politiker einen
rollenverständnis aus dem vergangenen
jahrhundert
frauen sind eben auch im parlament eine
wichtige unterstützung auch für uns in
der fraktion wichtige unterstützung das
rief einer fraktionskollegin auf dem
plan
die philipp anton mahl erklärt hat wir
sind hier nicht um die kaffee zu kochen
lieber kollege arthur wir unterstützen
nicht nur als wir machen politik für
gute stimmung hat dagegen mal eine
spd-abgeordnete gesorgt als sie diesen
merksatz ins parlament dreht immer gar
wir räumlich die hälfte des kuchens wir
wollen die hälfte der bäckerei beim
thema frauenquote geht es also oft hob
er im parlament dass selbst ich habe es
ja am anfang schon gesagt ein riesiges
frauenproblem hat kurz gesagt das hohe
haus ist ein herrenhaus ratet mal wie
viele der 700 neun abgeordneten frauen
sind 221 das sind rund 31 prozent
deutlich weniger als im letzten
parlament da waren es 36 prozent
ihr fragt euch woran das liegt vor allem
an frauen anteil der parteien die keine
frauenquote haben cdu/csu 21 fdp 22
prozent und die afg hat gerade mal 11
prozent
bis heute gab es seit der wende gerade
mal sechs ministerpräsidentinnen und
jetzt ratet mal wie viele
ministerpräsidenten ist seit 1990 gab
ich habe das nachgezählt es waren 68
bei meiner recherche bin ich auch ein
paar echte fundstücke im archiv gestoßen
hier zum beispiel 1 aus dem jahr 1986 da
sagt der damalige bundeskanzler helmut
kohl doch tatsächlich dass sich was tun
muss um mehr frauen in die politik zu
bekommen
ich halte dafür dass die parteiführungen
die darin eine adresse gesprochen
endlich aufraffen von einem teil jenes
pascha thoms abstand zu nehmen und die
parteidelegierten auch den privaten
leben links nicht mehr praktizieren wir
sind hier auf einem weg der ganz
zwangsläufig in eine richtung führt und
wenn doch männern der verteidigung
schlachten schlagen wird das bistum bei
den bundeskanzler
warum eigentlich nicht helmut kohl als
vorkämpfer der frauensache
sensationell ganze 20 jahre später wird
es diesen ersten weiblichen
bundeskanzler dann tatsächlich geben
angela merkel kohls mädchen die frau aus
dem osten die er 1991 selbst zur
frauenministerin machte wird erste
deutsche kanzlerin
und dieses foto wird dann oft gezeigt
als beleg dafür was mit merkel alles
möglich war
merkel die kanzlerin von der leyen auf
dem sprung nach brüssel
annegret kramp karrenbauer neue
verteidigungsministerin und cdu-chefin
frauen problem gelöst denkt ihr
vielleicht aber in wahrheit ist das
frauenproblem in merkels partei mit ihr
nicht kleiner geworden seit 1996 gibt es
ein unverbindliches frauenquorum in der
cdu schaut mal wie sich die frauen
damals gefreut haben ungefähr genauso
lange dient merkel selbst als alibi
dafür nichts zu tun hier ein bericht
meiner kollegin aus dem jahr 2001 berlin
direkt und da wird immer wieder angela
merkel genannt die vorzeige frau an der
spitze einer konservativen partei
was braucht man da eine quote das sollen
die anderen erstmal nachmachen und das
ist der frauen stand in der partei der
kanzlerin heute die cdu kreisverbände
sind immer noch zu 85 prozent männlich
in 17 landesverbänden gibt es nur eine
landesvorsitzende und es gibt aktuell
keine cdu-ministerpräsidentin es sind
nicht so viele momente bekannt in denen
sich die kanzlerin selbst für die quote
stark gemacht hat einen hab ich 2018
gesehen beim deutschlandtag der jungen
union
der geschäftsführende bundesvorstand der
jungen union schön männlich aber 50
prozent des volkes fehlen und ich sage
ihnen frauen bereichern das leben nicht
nur im privaten ohren politischen das
war eine mini ruhige und was meint ihr
hat das einen von den jungs der jungen
union beeindruckt zwar hat die junge
union den frauenanteil im bundesvorstand
inzwischen von 23 auf 40 prozent
angehoben die frauenquote aber leben sie
weiter mehrheit sich ab da twittert zum
beispiel der landesvorsitzende der
jungen union hamburg
rund 70 prozent der delegierten lehnen
eine frauenquote in der cdu ab die junge
union bleibt ein hort der vernunft und
wie sieht es bei der bundes partei aus
dass die frauenquote beim
bundesparteitag zur abstimmung steht
dafür hat die scheidende parteichef in
annegret kramp karrenbauer selbst
gesorgt als vermächtnis sozusagen klar
ist aber auch die drei möglichen
nachfolger als parteichef die bei dem
bundesparteitag zur wahl stehen die
kommen an den frauen aus zwei gründen
nicht vorbei erstens bei der letzten
bundestagswahl erhielt die cdu 30 der
gültigen zweitstimmen von frauen
zweitens sind da noch die delegierten
auf dem bundesparteitag selbst ein
drittel der 1101 delegierten sind frauen
also die frauen sind in der cdu zwar
unterrepräsentiert sie sind aber ein
wichtiger machtfaktor für jeden mann der
cdu chef und oder kanzler werden will
also noch mal kurz festgehalten die
kanzlerin partei ist männer partei
geblieben aber die quote steht gerade
aus wahltaktischen gründen trotzdem hoch
im kurs
bleibt die frage ob sie ein
langfristiges projekt bleibt denn
eigentlich hat die quote unter
konservativen und liberalen eher ein
looser image nach dem von ihnen
angestrebten quote für
bundestagsmandaten nach geschlecht
frauen männer und natürlich die diversen
kommt doch als nächstes die quote für
junge alte schule übergewichtige und
deutsche mit migrationshintergrund das
ist nichts anderes als die rückkehr zum
gruppen rechten wie im mittelalterlichen
ständestaat kurz gesagt frauenquote ist
mittelalter okay die aussage hat schon
alleinstellungsmerkmal
aber hier jetzt auch noch mal der
klassiker kompetente und fähige frauen
setzten sich auch ohne quoten durch auch
wenn sie es nicht wahrhaben wohl kleiner
einschub es gibt auch noch die die
eigentlich gegen die quote sind aber aus
modernität gründen dann doch dafür
vielleicht später kommt der vorschlag
dass wir eine männliche und weibliche
doppelspitze im vorsitz brauchen dann
diskutieren wir das machen das
vielleicht weil man nachfolger erst bei
meinem nachfolger auf die idee dass ihm
eine frau nachfolgen könnte ist
christian lindner erst gar nicht
gekommen so jetzt noch mal für euch
zusammengefasst was die gegner gegen die
quote vorbringen erstens sie öffnet tür
und tor für minderheiten das ist vor
allem das argument der afd
und faktisch natürlich fragwürdig weil
frauen keine minderheit sind sondern die
hälfte der bevölkerung außerdem ihr
erinnert euch gleichberechtigung steht
im grundgesetz zweitens sie ist ein
politisches 20 room and drittens sie
diskriminiert männer und viertens sie
macht aus frauenquoten frauen nicht
unbedingt hilfreich um die frauenquote
auf die erfolgsspur zu setzen auch die
parlamente haben es bisher eher
vermasselt zwei gesetze die die
frauenquote voranbringen wollten sind in
thüringen und brandenburg gescheitert
wenn ihr mehr zu diesen paris
hec gesetzen wissen wollt findet ihr
infos hier 2009 10 hat sich sogar eine
arbeitsgruppe aus 44 abgeordneten alle
fraktionen bis auf die idee zusammen
getan wenn ich heute nach dieser
arbeitsgruppe frage heißt es heillos
zerstritten die groko will das thema
frauenquote lieber im zuge der
wahlrechtsreform behandeln
voraussichtliche ergebnisse haltet euch
fest 2023 und jetzt der vierte grund
warum die frauenquote nicht zieht
frauen sind ja selbst auch teil des
problems das höre ich auf sie leben
führungsjobs ab verzichten zugunsten der
familie wollen gar nicht unbedingt fakt
ist frauen kandidieren seltener
engagieren sich seltener politisch woran
liegt das
eine studie der europäischen akademie
für frauen in politik und wirtschaft hat
mehr als 1000 kommunalpolitikerinnen
befragt und kommt zu dem schluss es
liegt an den strukturen mehr als die
hälfte der politikerin nannte auf die
frage was ihnen nicht gefällt die
männlich geprägten parteistrukturen mit
endlosen abendtermin grabenkämpfen
profilierungssucht vetternwirtschaft und
dann gilt halt je weniger frauen in der
politik sind desto weniger verändern
sich die strukturen desto weniger frauen
wollen in die politik und so weiter
bleibt das dogma quotenfrauen meistens
sind es ja junge frauen die sagen sie
würden es auch alleine schaffen uns so
ist das auch in der politik das narrativ
bösen man gar keine frau hochkommen
lassen will
in die vorstände das stimmt einfach
nicht sagt absoluter blödsinn jede frau
die was kann wird auch in dieser folge
geschlossen
interessanterweise sind es dann ältere
politikerinnen die sagen an die fairness
der männer im politischen betrieb zu
glauben war und ist
ich wohne gegnerin droht weil ich immer
gedacht habe wir bringen doch was wir
schaffen das schon und passiert ist
relativ wenig also im schneckentempo
weiter dicke rita süssmuth die grund
dann der gleichberechtigung in der union
hat ja schon 1994 das qualitäts argument
auseinandergenommen
es ist es nonsens und unsinn
rote gegen qualifikation zu stellen das
bedeutet ja dass wir der meinung sind
wir bringen weniger qualifikationen ein
wenn wir mehr frauen während 26 jahre
später sagt rita süssmuth in einem
interview mit uns gegen dieses heute
noch behaupten die schöpfen wir ohne
diese nur noch beweispflichtig
die geduld hat auch ein ende
also wir fassen noch mal zusammen warum
eine idee die schon so lange zur debatte
steht und zu der sich so viele auch
bekennen politisch nicht richtig zündet
die bilanz der frauenquote sieht nach 40
jahren so aus da wo sie gilt sind mehr
frauen in der politik da wo sie nicht
gilt sind es weniger eine kanzlerin hat
die sache der frauen auch nicht
unbedingt befördert der gesetzgeber hat
nicht unbedingt dick lenz und die frauen
selbst treten zu oft den rückzug an
es gibt mehrheitlich die politische
einsicht im parlament dass es so nicht
bleiben kann aber getan hatte sich
bisher nicht viel
bleibt die frage ob die neuen
konservativen fürsprecher wie merz und
söder fürsprecher für die frauenquote
nach der wahl bleiben und wie seht ihr
das wird sich was ändern ohne die
frauenquote in der politik muss sich
überhaupt was ändern schreibt mir gerne
hier unten in die kommentare
übrigens der frauenanteil in unserer
politischen hauptstadt redaktion liegt
bei 42 prozent
wenn ihr noch mehr argumente für und
gegen die frauenquote hören wollt dann
empfehle ich euch diese folge des neuen
zdf youtube formats 13 fragen und
abonniert unseren kanal inside politics
da gibt es immer exklusive einblicke in
den politischen betrieb von meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]